This video is brought to you by Swedish pod.
One Oh one pod one Oh one courses are one of my favorite ways to start learning
a new language online,
click the link in the description for a free lifetime account to give it a try.
Hello, everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel.
And my name is Paul in the recent video on the Swedish language,
we focused on the history of Swedish as well as some of its major features,
but Swedish is also an incredibly expressive language with colorful slang,
expressions and idioms. Today, we're going to focus on some common slang,
and then we're going to look at some widely used idioms,
but Shung meaning bro, or brother.
The main word for brother is [inaudible] from which this is obviously derived.
Ahem, that what's happening. Another common expression is by dose.
Meaning what's up. Well,
it literally means what is being done by [inaudible]
. This is like what's happening, bro. About Sheila
. I'm just chilling. This comes from the American English slang, chill out or.
Chill [inaudible] I do footfall on the bark is,
are you still hung over? Barcus is short for Bach full,
which means hung over your joy.
[inaudible].
Yeah, I saw you pass out on the sofa last night.
The formal meaning of that is literally DEC both in the sense of a
floor and the sense of decking, someone in other words, hitting them.
But in this slime usage, it's an intransitive verb.
Like you decked on the sofa with the meaning of you passed out.
This guy should consider drinking a little bit less.
Spesh the formal word for beer and Swedish is a cognitive,
the English word ale, but there's also a slang word Besh.
It came from the phrase biased, meaning Bavarian beer,
which turned into bias. And then it was further shortened to Besh.
This may not be classified as genuine slang since it's been in use for a long
time, but it's at least distinctly informal.
There's also another informal word for beer, which originally came from Italian.
[inaudible] bad in Swedish, but all means good.
And OU is a negation prefix like an in English.
So it's like saying and good in English, which is not an official English word,
but you could use it in a slimy way and it would work.
The Swedish word is kind of like that.
The formal way of saying bad is though I lit or Interborough,
which means not good. Who does he know? How has your beer guns got?
[inaudible] pretty bad. A similar word is cool. Uncool.
The formal way of saying it is in the Cooley. Meaning not cool.
This prefix can be added freely to lots of different adjectives to create a new
slimy word Lang focus.
Ooh, cool. [inaudible] cool. Letter.
Lang focuses on cool Pewdie pie as cooler.
You ain't sweetie.
If you don't have committed, bro, that's just a fact.
Another word that can be used to mean cool fact,
which literally means fat informal Swedish, the unfit.
That's a cool car.
Another common slang word is this one that means angry luck.
I'm luck. He got angry.
Um, like for yourself, I'm a fields. Mimi. I'm not cool.
He got angry because I said he was fat, but I meant he was.
Cool. I'm dumb luck for certain fields may or not cool
bucks to steal
[inaudible].
The rich guy got angry because someone stole his champagne. Steve. It,
this literally means griller as in someone who grilled steak, but in slang,
it refers to a snobby rich guy who likes to flaunt his wealth in the bars of
Stockholm. These guys are famous for at Vasca panning,
as in panning for gold in slang,
it means ordering two bottles of champagne and dumping out the contents of one
of them just to show off how rich they are.
The good news is that people who do stupid, things like that with their money,
usually don't stay rich for very long. In recent decades.
Some slang has also entered Swedish from immigrant languages in particular
Turkish, but also Arabic. And some others.
This slang is more widely used in immigrant communities,
but it's also used to a lesser extent by young people in general,
one such word is Kith, meaning bad.
The tea at the end here indicates the neuter form.
This comes from the Arabic word cave or Kaif meaning pleasure or fun.
The meaning became reversed from positive to negative and Swedish.
They kept that's bad.
They add a gift part.
Of this means money. And this is a lone word from Turkish INO.
This means police. This comes from Turkish highnesses,
which means without mirror an expression used in Turkish to refer to police in a
negative way,
meaning that they're shameless and can't look at themselves in the mirror.
The funny thing is that in Swedish, they just say, I know.
So they're referring to police as mirrors rather than as people who can't look
in the mirror, Swedish speakers, don't only use slang.
They also use lots of colorful idioms.
Some of which seem truly bizarre in translation in [inaudible] its
literal translation is no danger on the roof. It means no worries.
Or there's nothing to worry about.
Another idiom with a similar meaning is being in cool. Put your sun,
which literally means no cow on the ice. This is taken from a longer idiom.
[Inaudible].
Which literally means there is no cow on the ice.
As long as the button is still on land.
[Inaudible]. But.
Literally now you have taken a in the blue cabin.
You say this to someone who has really messed up and created a problematic
situation.
[Inaudible] literally.
Slide in on a shrimp sandwich.
You say this when you were lucky and something turned out to not require much
effort or work on the other hand, when you gave your best shot,
but you were unsuccessful and it didn't turn out. As you expected,
you might say no to cool stuff. Let's get sticked. Literally.
Now the boiled pork is fried. Some Swedish,
idioms are similar to ones used in English.
So [inaudible], this literally means the way you make your bed. You have to lie
in it in
English. We have a similar idiom. You've made your bed now lie in it. And there are numerous variations of the city
of an
English. Basically it means you'll have to live with the consequences of your own actions.
[inaudible]
this means butterflies in the stomach,
meaning something like an anxious feeling.
They let some implants. Literally that's easy as a pancake.
And it simply means that's really easy in English.
We have a number of expressions like this. One of them is easy as pie though.
That's a pretty outdated expression and no one really uses it anymore.
Maybe that's something my grandmother would say,
but another similar expression might be it's a cakewalk,
both expressions mean that something's really easy to do.
[inaudible] by the peg in the bag.
This is similar to the English idiom by a pig in a poke poke,
meaning sack or bag in both languages.
It means to buy something without examining the item first so that it might not
be exactly what you expect it to be. It might be fake low quality or broken,
et cetera.
I'm sure I'm just barely scratching the surface of Swedish slang and idioms.
But the great thing about social media is that you can participate in the
comments. So Swedish speakers,
why don't you write your favorite slang and idioms in the comments down below
and speakers of other languages.
If you have any similar slang or idioms in your languages,
you can tell us about those two. If you're excited to learn more Swedish,
then click the link in the description to visit Swedish pod one Oh one or visit
Lang focus.com/swedish pod.
I really recommend you check out innovative languages courses,
whether for Swedish or one of the other 33 languages,
they offer click the link in the description to get a free lifetime account.
I also want to give a big shout out to all the Lang focus, Patrion supporters,
especially the top tier patrons whose names are on the screen. Check out
patrion.com/lang focus and check out the benefits of the various tiers and to
everyone. Thank you for watching and have a nice.
Dang.